computing in the early 70s was the
classic day of the mainframes really and
at the time our mainframe was from a
British company was called ICL
international computers limited you know
it was our patriotic duty in the UK to
use our CL computers many places wanted
to have an IBM computer but they were
more expensive there were American
they were import restrictions and within
the universities in the UK I think only
two or three are allowed to have IBM's I
know where Cambridge was one Newcastle
was another the problem with all of this
is computers are expensive we the
university can only afford one you will
have to share it among yourselves and
there's quite a culture clash even in
those days the engineers civil engineers
whatever structural engineers wanted to
do their calculations physicists
chemists wanted other calculations
biologists and as we know even people
from the arts faculty wanting to run
music synthesis programs we all had to
share this certainly wasn't networks and
Ethernet across the campus know if you
were lucky what you got was what we used
to call the dumb terminal these things
were just a screen and a keyboard
there's no embedded processor in the
screen no secret computer micro
computers are not been invented you had
a lump of cable coming out of the back
of this thing probably going through
your building somehow or another and
ending up down in the traditional deep
basement somewhere leading into a shared
mainframe and what happened with
mainframes was you either arrived with
the deck of cards or a paper tape and
you ran what's called a batch job you
could hand over your job and a bit later
on in the day back would come your line
printer paper with the results on or if
you're one of the favored few you could
use one of these dumb terminals glass
teletypes that was sometimes called and
you were in the elite
were allowed to be an interactive user
and under very carefully controlled
conditions you could submit your
programs to the system if there was a
lot of output you were encouraged to get
it off a line printer if there was a
little bit you could get it back on your
glass teletype but it was not
sophisticated it really was not and
these mainframes were going bananas
trying to share themselves equally among
shall we say twenty or thirty
simultaneous users by today's standards
they were hopelessly underpowered so the
response was not good that's the sort of
disk this is we've looked it up it
doesn't say on the lettering what it is
we've looked up what a nashua 4464
capacity is it's 18 megabytes and let me
say again 18 megabytes not 80 gigabytes
and it's in this huge package the
platters in here have got the magnetic
media on there that stores you ones and
your zeros but it's not sealed in a
package where no dust can get in oh no
you put this down into a thing that
looks like loading washing machine in
the laundrette helpline oh good lord
yeah remember now you pull that down do
you know after I Steve about this it
might well be that you need a special
sort of spindle coming up in order to
release the platters I think you do
so can get the [ __ ] cover off and
pull it in with my top loader washing
machine but I can't at the moment figure
out how to get a little when you look at
the side here there's what one two three
four five 1602 yeah they'll be roughly
sixteen megabytes per platter many
people were longing to be able to get a
computer of their own that was powerful
enough to do what they wanted to do of
course computer scientists felt this
keenly
because in many ways we ended up being a
real bad shape in the family because not
so much I think that we wanted to run
patiently intensive things we didn't
tend to want to do massive molecular
orbital calculations or whatever that
could be done overnight the thing where
which made computer scientists resented
by the other law which is the computer
service providers and some stage we can
get into how these two split apart and
the answer is there was a lot of
bloodletting but eventually they did but
as far as the computer center the
computer service was concerned there
first while colleagues and computer
science were a complete pain they wanted
to run non-standard software in
non-standard ways this non-standard
software might crash the machine and
where would that leave the rest of the
time sharing users with the dead machine
all this kind of stuff so purely
personally my career's computer
scientist the teacher was fine we could
teach the students early languages that
we liked Fortran Algol were the first to
later on a version of Al Gore called
Algol 60 a teaching programming was no
problem we got a share for the students
and they were doing safe things in a
safe environment but for those who
wanted to do more dangerous things in
the research front yes you had to speak
very nicely to the director the
computing center and explained that you
wanted to run a particular version of
the Algol 68 language that you got from
some colleagues and it was non-standard
and it was trying to do real-time
programming with Al about 68 and who you
know will this affect the rest of the
users what happens if it goes wrong
wouldn't it be better to run it
overnight
eventually I think a lot of these
problems were sorted out but it became
very clear that as far as computer
scientists were concerned you'd love to
have a machine that was all your own
even if it was less powerful a little
bit than the mainframe and as the
seventies wore on this gradually became
possible and it became possible by
what's often called the second
generation after the mainframes came the
mini computers
some very famous names most of which
have now been absorbed or gone under
data general deck was very famous made
PDB 11 many computers and VAX many
computers so from my point of view
towards the end of the late seventies we
managed to save up enough money in the
computing section of the maths
Department to buy ourselves wait for it
a PDP 1105 mini computer you've got a
small amount of memory which capable of
taking in simple assembly level programs
on paper tape and they worked many
viewers of this will probably know about
programming languages you know like Java
C C++ and so on but of course it's a
level below that there is programming
that is much closer to the hardware and
you really did have to understand about
the innards on the machine to use it
effectively it's still with us is
assembler but nowadays higher-level
languages have got sufficiently much
more efficient the dissembler isn't
quite as important as it used to be so
anyway there we were we could run
assembler programs with our students for
the first time and it was it was a good
step forward but gradually we began to
hear on the computer scientist grapevine
towards the end of the center's that if
only you could afford a slightly bigger
PDP 11 I think was a PDP 11 34 was the
minimum there was this most amazing
operating system written by computer
scientists for computer scientists at
Bell Laboratories in the United States
and it was called UNIX and it did
everything just right and whereas a lot
of us had struggled with the mechanisms
on other operating systems for doing
multitasking multiprogramming
multi-access generally UNIX was
essentially written by one astonishingly
gifted programmer called Ken Thompson
you got one man's computer science view
of the universe
about how it should be done and for the
great majority of computer scientists it
just made your jaw drop open your
thought that is so clean that is so good
a very large number of computer science
departments as soon as they could want
and got themselves a minimal machine a
pdp-11 with a 50 or 80 megabyte discs
wait for it maybe 64 or 128 K of memory
and for those out there think I made a
mistake
no kilobytes not megabytes and certainly
not gigabytes and in that small amount
of memory the kernel of the operating
system had to run plus your program and
there was just sufficient amount of disk
that as long as you didn't have more
than five or six users on an
underpowered machine it was still slow
but he could swap between you park bits
of your program out on disk when it ran
out of memory space and generally be a
good clean multi-user multitasking
system underpowered sometimes absolutely
but it just changed everything it was
one of those seminal moments for
computer scientists we thought this is
just great and I think it was not only
the operating system itself because as
many people know the the two big names
in UNIX are Ken Thompson and Dennis
Ritchie and they were given the Turing
Award for inventing UNIX and for
inventing the C programming language and
although they shared the effort I think
to a first approximation you could say
that UNIX was Ken Thompson's creation
but the C compiler getting that working
refining it was very definitely
Dennis Rich's invention being
implemented by a limited number of
people who know what they are doing is
far far better than having an army of
programmers however that being said
you've got to be simpatico with the two
people who did it if they think the same
ways you do and their aim is the same as
yours you'll love it but if that's not
the case you may well end up hating it
so that was how eventually we ended up
with our more powerful pdp-11
in our basement in the math building
still air-conditioned and when we ran
out of steam on that we started thinking
all we've owned who could afford a more
powerful pdp-11 more memory bigger disk
and all this I have actually got a
photograph taken in the early 1980s of
our PDP 1170 this was a more powerful
PDP 11 it needed a three-phase electric
supply it ran up electricity bills like
there was no tomorrow the person you see
at the bottom of the picture the back
view I had more hair then that is me and
there's all my grad students around not
posed of course not in any way either
using VDU terminals or in the case of
Neil over there I persuaded him to look
as though he was putting a dump tape
onto the magnetic tape deck so that
would take a dump of the disk there was
none of this disk to disk dumping onto
terabyte backup disks that we have today
your main disk was precious you probably
couldn't afford lots and lots of them so
the dump of what had changed during the
day was done to magnetic tapes and those
of you with eagle eyes will see behind
me on my bookshelf a couple of non
trapped magnetic tapes containing I
think the source code of Sun
Microsystems version of UNIX well we
used to use blank tapes of that sort for
dumping and that will be done every
night and a big dump at the end of every
week but you knew the dump cycle was
happening you just hoped that if the
disk crashed you could recover from the
tape dump UNIX change of the world it
changed the world initially to prefer
for computer scientists it did also
change the world for everybody else but
it took some time because of the
licensing conditions from Bell
Laboratories who first issued it and
some more licensing conditions from
University of Berkeley who refined it a
bit more if you wanted to set up a
commercial UNIX opera
you needed a team of lawyers to
negotiate what you could and couldn't do
with bail and Berkeley source code and
of course the big computer manufacturers
didn't mind this too much but in the end
you felt well if if UNIX or its
derivatives
is going to rule the world and achieve
its full potential you've got to find
somebody who can reimplementation s--
where people are not going to be
hampered by endless restrictions on what
they can do what apps they can write and
so on that overall I would say took a
bit more than ten years I seem to
remember that some of the if you like
test open Souls type things I think this
guy called Andy Tannenbaum in Holland
did MINIX and then around about that
time the well-known name again Linus
Torvalds out in Finland really got hold
of this idea that to make unix-like
systems go mainstream you had to have a
standardised heart of the operating
system called the kernel and you had to
re-implement the whole thing in such a
way that people could set up their own
companies and under very clear
conditions know what they could do and
what they couldn't do and the rest as
they say is history I just do not know
but it's a very large number what
percentage of the world's servers now
run on UNIX or UNIX derived systems
nowadays various flavors of Linux it's
enormous
the system will
there is in size one fryer and dust
fridge have been recorded on their
[ __ ] additionally where you from
those fairies on it it stores a voice
one frequency with care beyond every
agency on yours a normal lady p11 for
free is always look for unique system
depressed I stopped that and I have to
rewind it again now